together
they were killed while they slept two
rockets which hit these military
Barracks with devastating accuracy
the bodies of around 50 soldiers
possibly more now buried under Rubble
many were new recruits who recently
enlisted to fight this war Alexander
says he was sleeping here when the
Russian missiles struck
there was no more air to breathe I put
on this mask and sat down close to the
floor took my gun and turned on the
light on my phone it was until I got
outside but I realized what had happened
it's possible that the death toll could
be as much as 200. for now fellow
soldiers are left to pick through the
debris trying to identify their fallen
friends Mika live is a port city one of
several now caught up in a battle for
the South which appears to be
intensifying in mariopol a city
surrounded by Russian aggression there's
not much left homes cars streets
destroyed when I left Mario Party it was
Eighth Day of invasion
it felt like the most brutal hell but
now what they do now with Russians do
now is just complete a discrimination of
the whole city of the civilians
everything if they are coming from from
the sky this guy hell is coming from the
sky tomorrow
there are reports now of Street Fighting
Russian troops are said to be moving
closer to the Heart of the City and
those left to defend it are desperate
leaders of the U.S and France you've
promised us air defense systems but what
we've received is not quite it look at
the city this is only part of the city
that's been destroyed by the enemy
planes by The Plains of Russia you've
promised that there'll be help give us
that help Biden and macron you are great
leaders beat them to the end save the
civilian population children elderly
people are dying
Ukraine's President Vladimir zielinski
handing out medals to troops today has
appealed for face-to-face peace talks
we were always insisting on the
negotiations we were always offering
dialogue offering a solution for peace
not only during the 23 days of invasion
and I want everyone to hear me now
especially in Moscow the time has come
for a meeting it is time to talk the
time has come to restore territorial
integrity and justice for Ukraine
otherwise Russia's losses will be such
that it will take you several
generations to recover the obliteration
of cities like Mario Paul is a stark
symbol of what this war is becoming
a war of attrition destroy to conquer
ukrainians are left hoping that peace
talks will amount to something before
more Cities end up looking like this
Nick Martin Sky news Ukraine